hi I'm Joe Dante here at trailers from
how we featured a lot of films by the
late William Castle whose career was
separated basically into several
different categories one he was a studio
director directed a lot of pictures at
Columbia and Universal then he struck
out on his own as an independent and hid
being in the horror field and worked at
Columbia again for a couple of years and
then he started to bounce around from
Studio to studio the picture we're gonna
look at today is actually one of his
later pictures from his league period
it's got a lot of fans even though it's
not on DVD and is kind of hard to see
it's called the night Walker every day
people are about to relive their dreams
under hypnosis they are not actors
prolific pulp mystery writer Robert
blocks Hollywood career took off when
Hitchcock based psycho on his novel soon
both TV and feature films beckoned him
block came right off the episode right
off block came right off ten episodes
each of thriller on the Hitchcock hour
to work with the poor man's Hitchcock
William Castle who had taken the Masters
example to heart and merchandised
himself as a purveyor of Menace even to
introducing his own movies as himself
following a failed TV pilot called the
plot thickens
both men hit pay dirt with the Joan
Crawford vehicle straightjacket and
followed up with Barbara Stanwyck last
feature film the night Walker the promos
for this were pretty upfront lurid for
the day the plumy voice of Paul frees
sets up the premise and an arresting
prologue about dreams and nightmares and
how when we dream we become night
walkers
Barbara Stanwyck talks in her sleep
meeting her blind but nasty husband to
suspect her of cheating on him when he
dies in an explosion is now rich widow
is plagued by dreams that he's after her
or is she that is the voice of a woman
asleep dreaming does her lover exist is
he real or is he only a dream
this can happen to you too presence of
Stanwix one-time husband robert taylor
was great for Golden Age publicity but
the movie still fizzled at the box
office despite the usual castle promo
blitz however over the years the night
Walker has developed a devoted fan base
despite its unavailability on DVD
perhaps the most memorable aspect of the
whole enterprise as the propulsively
creepy music score by Vic Mizzy which
probably helped get him the music
assignment on the Addams Family TV show
block went on to do more Hitchcock
episodes and a number of amicus horror
omnibuses Castle eventually moved on to
parama where he produced but did not
direct his finest picture Rosemary's
Baby did you kill your husband
if you do do not see the nightwalker
it might be too much for you
you